اسرائيل تقتحم جنين ومخيم بلاطه وتقتل
ثلاثه فلسطينيين حل محتمل قد يلجا اليه
بايدن في ازمه سقف الديون مركبه رايدي
الفضاء السعوديين تلتحموا بمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من
قناه العربيه فاهلا بكم الى التفاصيل
في عمليه اقتحام جديده لضفه الغربيه داهمت
قوات كبيره من الجيش الاسرائيلي عده احياء
من مدينه جنين واعتقلت عددا من
الفلسطينيين وذلك بعد مقتل ثلاثه
فلسطينيين برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في
مخيم بلاطه بمدينه نابلس اثره اقتحامه في
ساعات الصباح الباكر الناطق باسم رئاسه
الفلسطينيه نبيل ابو ردينه قال انما حدث
في المخيم مجزره حقيقيه كاستمرارا للحرب
الشامله على الشعب الفلسطيني وطالبا اداره
الامريكيه بالتدخل الفوري لوقف ما وصفه
بالجنود الاسرائيلي
مع استمرار البحث عن حلولا لازمه سقف
الدين في الولايات المتحده سبقت صحفنا
امريكيه لقاء الرئيس جو بايدن برئيس مجلس
النواب كامل مقارتي بالحديث عن احتمال
اللجوء بايدن الى التعديل الرابع عشر من
الدستور وذلك لرفع سقف في دير الحكومه
الاتحاديه البالغ 31.4 تريليون دولار
الصحف الامريكيه اشارت الى بايدن قد يتجنب
هذا الحل بسبب ضيق الوقت فيما يحث بعض
الديمقراطيين الرئيس الامريكي على محاوله
استخدام هذا التعديل الذي لم يسبق اللجوء
اليه من اجل تجاوز مجلس النواب الذي يسيطر
عليه الجمهوريون ورفع حد الاقتراض
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو 16 ساعه على انطلاقها تمكنت مركبه
دراغون التي تحمل رائدي الفضاء السعوديين
ريان برناوي ابو علي القرني تمكنت من
التحام بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه بنجاح برناوي
والقرني كانا ارسل وارسل اول رساله من
الفضاء اعربا فيهما عن فخرهما لهذه المهمه
مؤكدين ان هذا العصر هو عصر التمكين
والازدهار حيث بدات السعوديه امس مهمه
فضائيه تاريخيه بارسال الرائدين برناوي
والقرني تعاونت في تنظيمها وكاله الفضاله
الامريكيه ناسا وشركه فيس اكس وشركه اكس
والهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
في قرار مزعج لمارك فرض الاتحاد الاوروبي
غرامه ضخمه على شركه ميتساب ملكه فيسبوك
بلغت 1.3 مليار دولار لفشلها في حمايه
المعلومات الشخصيه للمستخدمين اللجنه
لحمايه البيانات التي تتحرك نيابه عن
الاتحاد الاوروبي قالت ان المجلس الاوروبي
لحمايه البيانات امرها بتحصيل الغرامه من
متى فيما اعلنت متى انها ستطعن على ان
قرار وطلبتها اللجنه بتعليم في اي نقله
مستقبلي للبيانات الشخصيه الى الولايات
المتحده
خبرنا الاخير من المانيا حيث اصبحت حقيبه
قديمه للمستشار اولافشوت حتى منافسه بين
متحف التاريخي في المانيا ومؤسسه فكريه اذ
يسعى كلاهما للحصول على هذه الحقيبه
الحقيبه كان يحرس الشوطس على استخدامها
منذ اربعين عاما وايضا اصبحت رفيقته خلال
كل لقاءاتها الدبلوماسيه حول العالم اصبحت
محطه انظار الكاميرات اضحى في التاريخ في
بوننا يرغب هو الاخر في اضافه الحقيبه الى
مجموعته التي تضم ارائك مخمليه وهواتف من
طراز سيمنز اس 5 لكن ليس معروف اذا كان
المستشار سيستغني عن هذه الحقيبه ام لا
[موسيقى]